hey what's up guys my name is a Chino
and welcome to episode number 13 of the
sterilization series so last time we
finished off our entire civilization
section everything was the best we
managed to implement strings and with
that we kind of closed the whole initial
at least initial path of of actually
serializing data one thing that I
overlooked unfortunately was in RC
object is a quick bug fix here in this
in our size calculation we're not
actually factoring in string count okay
so you can see that we've got the in
size here then we've got the two shots
but there's we're missing one of the
shots okay so just add plus two in there
and we should be good to go all right
anyway that aside if we still eyes this
out everything should work we're going
to talk about reading now Saudi
serialization right how can we actually
go through and deserialize data now the
way that this is going to work is going
to be kind of recursive in the sense
that it's not really going to be
recursive because we don't exactly have
objects within objects yet and we're
actually not going to do that at least
not in the initial pass because it's not
something that we really require for
game programming I feel and I mean if
you wanted to do that it would not be
too difficult right again you you would
either decide whether or not you wanted
to have inside object you would
basically just have another list of RC
objects along with an object count and
then you would see relies them in order
that's it right and then again if you
wanted that table at the beginning that
said where everything was you could do
that as well but it's really not that
difficult to add and it's just yeah I'm
just not really in the mood I don't
think we need it basically okay anyway
again if it's really like heavily
requested or something I will add it to
my like list of extended kind of stuff
that I will do along with them along
with optimization but for now we should
be good to go so anyway um what we'll do
today is again distillation so how does
that work well it's actually not that
difficult a lot of people were saying
that this might be difficult to read and
that some things this is the kind of the
hard part and I will
say that yes it is the hard part right
serializing data is a lot easier than
deserialising it usually okay it's just
easier to kind of just write a bunch of
bytes and it is to actually read it
that's just the way that it works but
first of all let's just let's just come
up with a nice API so the way that I
want this to work is ideally all you
should be able to do so this is our kind
of reading test I actually might save
this out all of our writing test public
static void serialization test right and
I'm just going to grab pretty much all
of this and cut it and paste it here so
this method should contain everything we
need to actually see relies something i
guess i'll add in that array is a lot
just for fun whereas over here so if we
call sterilization test right now it
will obviously civilized everything
we're going to also of course make a
public static void d serialization test
right and these trial version does is
going to do the opposite so the API that
we're going to use is going to be very
similar to kind of the way that we did
this right except it's going to be a lot
easier we should just be able to say our
see a database you know whatever
database equals RC database still
deserialize and then usually like we
would maybe give it like a stream of
bytes okay or maybe even there would be
a DC realized from file in our case
which would take in that file path which
I believe is just test adult LCD alright
so that's the way that that's going to
work so let's create that method
there'll be two methods right they'll be
digitalized from file and they'll just
be to serialize again something like
this utilize might be useful if you
receive it not from a file like from a
network stream or something because
usually you know you would just want to
kind of just serialize a stream of bytes
it doesn't have to be doesn't really
have to be in an actual it doesn't
actually have to get it doesn't actually
have to be like from a file or anything
obviously so string path okay so this
will be very simple it'll basically do
the reverse
of what buffered outputs trimmed did it
will just be a buffered input stream so
if we bring that over here so buffered
input stream right it's going to be a
new file input stream with that path
there I'll control shift odo and for
that then what we'll do is we'll
actually read it reading the whole
section right and to do that all we
really need to do is so there's a few
ways that we could probably do this so
maybe not right so read up to bite
length by the data from this input
stream into an array of bytes okay
pretty pretty simple so we'll do read
will create a byte array now does this
say how let's see method blocks me
simply perform the call read and returns
the result is one that is not right so
buffer total number of bytes right into
the buffer I'm not sure if you actually
that actually makes a new buffer though
or what does it do would be okay if
buffer equals null in it okay so
obviously you need to give it a buffer
so we'll do something like bite oops
bytebuffer equals new bites stream not
available which i assume is the size
estimate okay that's yeah all right
hopefully that estimate is accurate
sorry if you have noticed is literally
the first time I've had done this in
Java okay so we'll do streamed all read
and then that's it so if that was
successful I assume we'll just not
return null so we'll say buffer equals
null for now then we'll set that up and
then we'll return buffer I'll sorry
we're gonna return buffer will return
deserialize buffer okay so that should
be that should be like a pretty much all
that our file does and then this will
actually do the reading so how is that
going to work well remember the first
thing we need to do is we need to
literally start off with where I we need
to literally start off with the database
which is this right we have to start
reading all these bites we can do
certain assertions along the way such as
checking to make sure the first four
bicycle RC
DB and all that stuff but eventually
like we're going to have to pop into the
actual object class and then start
writing dis evaluation methods in that
class okay so let's begin we're going to
initialize our pointer variable like
usual and then the first thing I'm going
to do is is probably check to make sure
that actually is correct so in our in
our civilization writer class where we
have all this stuff I don't suppose we
have a read string or anything like that
reading strings from byte arrays I
assume we can just create a new string
from a bunch of bites right and I assume
you can probably give it a value so in
offset and into length as well okay
fantastic so what we will do is in our
civilization writer class which again is
more of a it's it does both it's both a
reader and a writer at this point in our
read bytes that we have down the bottom
will have a public static string red
string there's going to be a bite source
and a pointer of course except this time
also specify length whoops and then all
this will do is return string I mean we
could add some sessions obviously
welcome to do that right now sauce
pointer length okay and that should be
fine now I forget what the actual method
was where were we in Nancy database so
what was that what we were looking at
because I know that it was something
like and I wasn't offset int'l inc okay
so what is your problem byte int int is
undefined what oh you
there we go cool so this will be our
source all right wonderful so now that
we've done that we can easily read in
the header by saying something like data
I sorry read string data pointer should
be pointer in this case length should be
four okay so let's just basically system
to out or print line our header and then
I'll kind of break here if I just do a
set of false is that going to just stop
I assume it will will return null for
the time being all right so let's bring
up hxd along with our file which is over
here so is our test one the other one
before we added that random array so r c
DB is what we expect it to of course
read from the first four bytes of the
file so let's go back to main let's say
this is going to be our digitalized from
file thing we're going to run to
sterilization test and then just we're
just gonna run it ok cool rcd be so it's
that false did absolutely nothing that's
just wonderful to know that man I was
expecting it to like break point there
or something I guess I can I could have
manually set a break point but anyway
you can say that our cdb is indeed the
header is indeed the head of the week
print okay so that worked I get a great
way to kind of do that as well as what
we typically would do is something like
a cert I don't even know if asserts of
useful at this point but a third-rate
springville r dot equals this right and
that'll just kind of make sure that we
are indeed are correct of course then
we'll have to advance pointer by four
bytes but anyway we can kind of do
checks like that right just ensure that
everything is going smoothly so next
thing we'll do we know is that we need
to read in the container type so we
expect that to be a database because we
are literally reading from a weird of
civilizing an entire database so let's
go ahead and do that make some space
here so we'll do something like it's a
bite right I mean we don't really have
to use read byte because of course we
could just say data pointer that's our
read byte it's up to you i don't know if
we want to be we probably do want to be
consistent so let's do read byte data
pointer alright so that'll be our our
container type and then again we can say
something like a cert container type
equals container type ganges making sure
that's accurate and then we can start
actually reading in data such as our
name length so what's our name legs
going to be again that's going to be
perfect because it's going to determine
what length our string needs to be in
fact I can probably just make sure that
actually does say head of the length was
rather than for just in case that
changes at any point and of course this
will then advance that pointer by ahead
of that length ok cool so um now what we
have to do is read in the net the size
of the thing so what I'll do is this
will actually be cast into an int
because the red string method takes in
an integra so I mean I don't actually
know if we really need to necessarily
cast that I think it might be implicitly
cast when we pass it through so let's
just try that so name length name length
is going to be read short source by the
way make sure we do point A plus plus
after we um read that so I'll actually
hang on yeah because this does not
advance the pointer that's another
important thing riding bites does it
returns a pointer it returns the new
pointer right after it's been
incremented however many times however
this doesn't so we actually need to do
that ourselves and again the reason that
we're doing that is because of Java's
non like not being able to pass integers
x value i don't really want to have to
make a new integer class to be able to
get that data back because that's going
to make our code look very messy so if
if data did if java did support like you
know passing primitives by reference
than i would
we just happen out pointer variables and
like that but anyway so we'll read short
which will be sauce as our data pointer
and is that it that is it will make sure
that we advance pointer by two now that
we have the name length we can again do
something where we actually read in the
string so this is actually something
that we're doing though right name
currently is unknown to us so his name
length and by the way what we can start
doing is instead of making local
variables like we did here we can
actually start saying this door name
length or in fact just name length right
now we can do this obviously it's static
but we'll have to make an object at this
point so I I'll see database result
equals new RC database it's undefined
okay so we need a name here okay that's
that's okay we'll make a private
constructor that doesn't take in a name
so we'll make that and then we'll start
actually setting that results name
length equal to whatever we need tubes
in this case it'll be read short right
then we'll do result dot name equals
read string data make sure you also
advance that pointer that was what that
was this will be data pointer and length
will be results name length okay so at
this point we should have it okay so it
looks like we will actually need to cast
it to an end that's a little bit in mine
or maybe not oh that's a bite thing okay
so I guess we'll do get bites so what do
we have to know we don't all right so I
guess we won't we'll make it look a bit
nicer and then of course pointer at this
point will be plus equals result name
length so this point we actually have
something that we can look at right if
we go into like we've got a set name
let's just say that we do have a get
name okay and a get named William will
return string and this will just return
new string
I mean I know this probably isn't
efficient having to create a new string
every time because that does have to
allocate memory for that buffer of
characters but you know this isn't an
operation that you call very often you
probably call it once anyway so caching
it isn't something that I'm necessarily
going to do anyway we will put in the
bytes so named the length or the offset
will be 0 and then the length will be
named line for a name dealt length would
have been the same kind of effect so
there we go in fact we could have just
done that I think because obviously it
nor is the thing but we'll we'll play it
safe okay cool so there we go so now
what we should be able to do is and at
this point I'll change our let's just
close all this stuff because it's
getting a bit in line at this point I'm
going to return result and they'll be
way down the track and then what I'll do
this is we have this database is I'll
call something like system dot out dot
print line database don't get name so
hopefully this should print out the name
of our database which according to this
file is just database okay and we can
see that over here in our civilization
test so let's run that and you can see
that we do indeed get database okay so
you guys can kind of see how this is
going to continue on it's going to
continue on in the same spirit that's
all that we're going to do it you can
reading is a little bit more difficult
but not really so don't worry too much
about this so let's write in the rest of
things size is our next thing that we
want to read in so we'll do result so
that's kind of the name result that size
is going to equal read int data pointer
and that's it and then we're going to do
point of plus equals 4 okay and that's
it and then will your object count
which is two and it is results dot
object count equals read short I think
it is yep data and pointer okay and then
we can actually start reading the
objects and i bet you guys are excited
to figure out how on earth we're going
to start reading the actual objects and
of course i want to save that for next
time because this video is already 17
minutes long but if we do take a look at
some of the things that we now have like
if i put a breakpoint here so that we
can inspect this if i run this and we
take a look at what database now as you
can see we have one object what was that
exciting things sighs sighs is negative
56 Wow let's let's just reassess that
real quick negative 56 clearly something
has gone wrong let's take a look here so
database and then we have an anti
believe which that's not negative 60 not
negative 58 so why did it not read that
int probably we did we did let's take a
look at this quickly I believe we
advanced the point of the correct amount
right name dot length or result name
length that's eight eight bytes forward
one two three four five six seven eight
okay that's correct so then size is
negative 56 why is sighs let's look at
what we didn't actually does maybe read
nth is wrong okay what do we have here
so that's looking correct to me ha that
is very odd that is very odd indeed that
looks totally fine to me hmm alright so
after a bit of digging of course I
realized to my disappointment that bites
in Java
are of course signed which is why we
were getting negative 56 so we can't
simply read an int or really anything by
just doing this unfortunately we do
actually have to use java's are kind of
built-in by buffer stuff I mean that'll
just make the conversion easier for us
because we don't have to but we can so
if I wrap the byte array sauce I assume
there's an offset on a length here as
well so we'll set the offset to pointer
and then length 24 we can get the int
from that and we can just return that
and that will be our end click on with
that out just for a bit here and then we
go over here and we hit of sex and we
look at result sighs then you can see
that new this case the size is 200 which
is above 127 aha which is why it did not
work for us because 127 is the maximum
we can portray with seven bits which is
all we getting since the eighth bit or
one of the eight bits was a sign bit so
anyway that's what we get by having
signed bytes whoever thought that was a
good idea seriously but anyway it's just
a little annoying that we have to do
that but all good we should probably do
that for all the other stuff as well
because we're going to have to do that
so unless we're returning a bite really
we need to convert everything to kind of
use this byte buffer wrap thing to
actually get the correct result back
cool so anyway now that we've read that
in and we've returned the result you can
see that what we get here is hopefully a
database that and that was another break
point there a database that has a size
of 200 which should be the size of the
file and indeed I believe it is and
everything is looks pretty good so
anyway that's going to wrap up this
video next video we're going to we're
going to we're going to correct these as
we go along but we'll also next video we
will also go into the the
destabilization of actual objects okay
because I'll probably be a bit more
complicated than just the database stuff
which is very basic alright thanks for
watching if you enjoyed the video please
hit the like button and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye